- Hi, I'm Ted.
With Harry Shearer retiring,
I'm auditioning for any part
I can get in the Simpsons.
(whip crack)
(marker squeaks)
(playful music)
Smithers, release the hounds. Excellent.
Hi-dilly-ho, neighbor!
Ok-ely, doke-ely, neighbor-ino!
One of the great exchanges
between Homer and Lisa:
But, Dad! I'm a vegetarian.
I don't eat animals.
But Lisa. Animals are so delicious.
There's the animal we get bacon from,
the animal we get ham from,
the animal we get sausage from...
Dad! That's all the same animal.
Oh, sure, Lisa. A magic animal
that all the wonderful foods come from.
Kang and Kodos in one of the great classic
episodes when they run for president.
I'm running for president, now,
and you know, it's really tough.
Forward, not backwards!
Upwards, not downwards!
And always twirling, twirling for freedom.
I have been told many times,
I have a face for radio, and
I have a face for animation.
(upbeat music)